y es el poder
[Música]
para algunos el poder es dinero para
otros el poder es un gran ejército pero
yo tengo otra definición poder significa
ser capaz de obligar a otros hacer
sacrificios en contra de su voluntad
solo porque tú quieres
pues bien eso es lo que va a probar
donald trump con la unión europea y cuál
es ese sacrificio que quiere imponer
trampa a los europeos pues es muy
sencillo
cortar sus relaciones con la república
islámica de irán
[Aplausos]
pero de verdad hablamos de un sacrificio
tan grande y lo que es más importante
hasta qué punto puede imponer donald
trump su voluntad en este vídeo te lo
vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
irán es un país famoso por varias cosas
las alfombras persas los programas de
enriquecimiento de uranio y los
automóviles sí amigos de visual política
irán es uno de los mayores fabricantes
de coches de todo oriente medio
[Música]
ya sé lo que estáis pensando tan pero si
es un país en vías de desarrollo pero si
están prácticamente aislados pues no
sólo fabrican coches es que además
tienen sus propias marcas
por ejemplo este coche que veis aquí es
el samán un sedan que se vende muy
bien no solamente en irán sino también
en azerbayán rusia y venezuela vale no
os esperéis ninguna maravilla por lo que
dicen las revistas especializadas sus
motores están obsoletos y los acabados
dejan mucho que desear sin embargo tiene
un precio imbatible siete mil dólares
[Música]
os imagináis lo que pasaría si le
pusiéramos unas pocas mejoras un sedan
de este tipo con un precio tan tentador
podría venderse en muchos otros países
sobre todo países en vías de desarrollo
y eso explica que a partir del año 2015
cuando se levantaron las sanciones a
irán muchísimas empresas europeas se
lanzarán a invertir en el país
3 no le entrará en una joint-venture en
irán
[Música]
elio citroën vuelven a irán para hacer
un acuerdo para fabricar coches pero no
sólo hablamos de coches veréis la bolsa
de teherán tiene una capitalización tres
veces más grande que por ejemplo la de
egipto y tienen todo tipo de empresas a
diferencia de otros países de la zona
que están dominados por el petróleo y
las materias primas irán tiene una
economía sorprendentemente diversificada
bancos minería y hasta
telecomunicaciones y eso también ha
traído a otro tipo de empresas europeas
[Música]
vodafone entran irán mediante una
asociación con highway por si todo esto
fuera poco irán tiene una población muy
bien educada la tasa de alfabetización
es mucho más alta que en siria irak o
muchos de los países vecinos más de 4
millones de ciudadanos estudian o han
estudiado en la universidad y eso
significa mano de obra muy cualificada y
dispuesta a trabajar por sueldos
relativamente bajos si a esto le sumamos
que el país tiene más de 80 millones de
habitantes y que está todo por hacer
tenemos que la república islámica de
irán es todo un destino para invertir
sin embargo toda esta oleada de dinero
europeo se acaba de frenar en seco
[Música]
trump dice que eeuu a instrucción hará a
las empresas europeas que hagan negocios
con irán pero esperad un momento vamos a
ver
donald trump es el presidente de eeuu
podrá imponer sanciones a las empresas
de su país pero europa que puede hacer
en europa como puede legislar sobre las
empresas de otros países donde al menos
en teoría no tiene jurisdicción porque
le iban a hacer caso es esto una
bravuconada de trump o tal vez no hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el duelo legislativo en marzo de 2018
zte que es una empresa de teléfonos
móviles china tuvo que pagar una multa
de unos mil millones de dólares a eeuu
[Música]
su delito importar microchips de eeuu y
venderlos en iran la casa blanca les
dijo aja así que haciendo negocios con
los malos de la película pues elegir o
me pagáis una multa millonaria o tenéis
prohibido vender cosas en mi país dejar
de vender en estados unidos el mercado
más rico del mundo
zte está dispuesta a pagar una multa y
no volver a pisar irán el resto de su
existencia y lo mismo está pasando con
muchas empresas pero como ya hemos dicho
las empresas europeas se han lanzado a
hacer negocios con irán no sólo hablamos
de compra de petróleo sino de
inversiones de todo tipo
[Música]
así que tan pronto como trump aprobó las
nuevas sanciones contra irán la unión
europea le plantó cara
[Música]
todo está exige excepciones a las
sanciones de trump para la energía
aviación y otros sectores básicamente
los líderes europeos escribieron una
carta a la casa blanca pidiéndole que
respetará a sus intereses económicos
como sabéis trump no es precisamente muy
amigo de la unión europea así que ya os
podéis imaginar su respuesta y por eso
el 7 de agosto de 2018 la unión europea
pasó a la acción se acabaron las cartas
y todo lo demás había llegado el momento
de activar la regulación 2.271
qué pasa que no sabéis lo que es la
regulación 2200 71 96 pues no pasa nada
hombre que para eso estoy yo para
explicar lo que es la regulación 2.271
[Música]
pues básicamente la regulación 2.271
6 es algo así como un escudo legal anti
guerras comerciales vamos a poner un
ejemplo imaginad que renault tiene una
fábrica en suelo iraní y chevrolet que
es una empresa estadounidense se entera
y les denuncia eeuu impondría una multa
a renault
pues bien automáticamente la unión
europea- impondría una multa equivalente
a chevrolet por daños y perjuicios
[Música]
pero no sólo eso si citroën dijera
yo no quiero problemas quita quita que
yo me voy a ir a la unión europea
también le pondría una multa porque
cualquier empresa europea que obedezca
las sanciones impuestas por washington
está incumpliendo la ley europea en
otras palabras que todas esas empresas
que estaban haciendo negocios con irán
lo están pasando mal si se quedan en el
país de los ayatolás golpe de remo por
parte de washington pero es que si se
marchan tienen un golpe de remo por
parte de bruselas se trata de todo un
duelo político quien tiene más poder que
golpe de remo van a preferir las
empresas europeas pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
la cruda realidad seguro que todos
vosotros habréis hecho alguna vez una
transferencia internacional por ejemplo
vivís en colombia y hacéis un trabajo
para una empresa australiana cuando
hacéis la factura no ponéis vuestra
cuenta de banco normal verdad en su
lugar ponéis un número muy largo con
unas letras raras algo así como estos
pues bien esas letras raras son el
llamado código swift el sistema swift
sirve para hacer transacciones
internacionales
[Música]
se trata de una red que conecta a casi
todos los bancos del mundo y durante
décadas irán estaba aislada de esta red
es decir que aunque alguien quisiera
hacer negocios con irán no podía por qué
porque cómo vas a hacer negocios con
alguien si no le puedes mandar dinero la
única opción sería mandar un maletín con
billetes y es un poco incómodo en el año
2015 cuando se aprobó el acuerdo nuclear
iran volvió a entrar en el sistema swift
y ese fue el auténtico momento en el que
irán pudo empezar a hacer negocios con
el extranjero
y os preguntaréis quien controla este
sistema pues efectivamente una empresa
que se llama swift ya que no adivina es
donde tienen la sede exacto en bélgica
en europa y ya se lo que estáis pensando
si todas las transacciones
internacionales se gestionan desde
europa y eeuu va a tener que tragarse
sus palabras en este duelo político
verdad pues os equivocáis veréis swift
es una sociedad cooperativa las
decisiones se toman en un consejo de
administración compuesto por 25
representantes de bancos de todo el
mundo y resulta que en este consejo de
administración hay dos estadounidenses
uno de citibank y otro de jp morgan
y muy probablemente estos dos
representantes tendrían que pagar multas
millonarias si no consiguen convencer a
sus compañeros de que swift desconecte a
irán de toda la red si esto llegara a
ocurrir a efectos prácticos iran
volvería a estar aislado del mercado
internacional si no puedes hacer
transacciones no puedes hacer negocios
es así de simple
se trata de algo tan importante que la
unión europea ya está intentando sacar
un sistema alternativo para poder hacer
transferencias internacionales algo así
como una versión moderna del trueque de
toda la vida lo llaman spv o vehículo
para propósitos especiales la idea es en
lugar de cambiar bienes por dinero
europa quiere pagar con créditos sobre
otros bienes por ejemplo imaginad que
repsol que es una empresa española que
quiere comprar un cargamento de petróleo
a irán pues bien en lugar de pagarle con
dinero podría pagar con una máquina que
valga lo mismo que los barriles que van
a comprar
ah
y os preguntaréis puede funcionar un
sistema así lo cierto es que solo el
tiempo lo dirá pero vamos a suponer que
si vamos a imaginar que las empresas
europeas empiezan a utilizar este
sistema spv para comerciar con irán
volvamos al ejemplo de repsol ese humo
de dinosaurio que ha comprado tendrá que
llegar de alguna forma verdad alguien
tendrá que transportarlo en un barco
petrolero hasta el puerto de barcelona
por ejemplo pues bien la mayor parte de
los buques petroleros del mundo los
controla una empresa de dinamarca que se
llama marx
pero cuidado porque no todo es tan fácil
para que ese barco de myers mike mike
myers para que ese barco danés pueda
descargar su mercancía en barcelona
tiene que estar asegurado ningún puerto
del mundo aceptaría un barco petrolero
si no está asegurado y resulta que casi
todas las compañías de seguros que
trabajan con petróleo son
estadounidenses o por lo menos tiene
muchísimos intereses en los estados
y eso explica noticias como esta
[Música]
el gigante del transporte marítimo marx
abandonará irán por las amenazas de
sanciones en otros países como china ya
han encontrado otras alternativas pero
de eso hablaremos en el siguiente vídeo
de esta serie lo cierto es que por la
cuenta que les trae les interesa
mantener el contacto con irán como sea
se trata del sexto proveedor de petróleo
más importante que tienen el 7 por
ciento de las importaciones de zumo de
dinosaurio en china vienen de teherán en
el caso de europa
las importaciones de iran son mucho más
pequeñas es decir que sí que irán es
importante que vale que todo lo que tú
quieras pero no es el recope team
[Música]
en otras palabras que si europa quisiera
seguir comprando zumo de dinosaurio irán
tendría que buscar nuevas empresas de
transporte nuevas empresas de seguros y
además comprarlo a través de él
trueque a ver
en esta vida todo es posible pero a
estas alturas de la película parece que
eeuu y donald trump le están ganando el
pulso a la unión europea- y todo esto
tiene varias consecuencias en este otro
vídeo os contábamos lo que está
ocurriendo con el mercado internacional
del petróleo en las próximas semanas
hablaremos de las posibles consecuencias
que puede tener para el régimen de los
ayatolás en irán mientras tanto la
pregunta es pueden estas sanciones
acabar con el régimen político de irán
hasta dónde pueden subir los precios del
petróleo
podéis dejarme vuestras teorías en los
comentarios y en los siguientes vídeos
veremos si coinciden con las nuestras y
como siempre no olvidéis que publicamos
nuevos vídeos todas las semanas así que
suscribió esa visual política y darle a
la campanita para que os lleguen todas
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Aplausos]
[Música]